foreign
[Music]
questions
join mug club today for 89 annually to
support content like this and get access
to the entire network
louderwithcraider.com mug Club
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Mr Crowder's undisposed so I'm back
here's gone away headphones a little bit
because it's set to Alex Jones level oh
wow uh glad to be with you thank you to
Mr Alex Jones for filling in yesterday
yeah you know that's my question before
we move on to anything else that's my
question for you how did you like Alex
Jones hosting yesterday comment uh
comment below look it's a different show
every now and then every few weeks every
couple of months you know I might need
someone to fill in have a business to
tend to and uh well you know we'll see
who we uh we end up getting in this
chair every now and then it's not easy
to do my blow up doll maybe yeah maybe
my headphones are a little bit
everything adjust it to Alex Valium so
well now you know why he's so amped up
all the time you sound a little lower I
sound a lot higher in my headphones than
you do well I mean you're also not
speaking into the mic like a like a
uh all right before I bring him
in look we have a lot to get into today
there's the Durham report
uh just so you know it's uh you know
they chalk it up to missteps not yet to
them they Chuck up to missteps that's
what we'll be talking about today they
Chuck it up to that so uh it turns out
everything that they said not true we'll
get into exactly what they were saying
then and what they're saying now now
here's the issue with the Durham report
the FBI probe right Russia collusion
let's just use that for those people who
aren't familiar uh it's election
interference and it's election
interference paid for by your tax
dollars our intelligence agencies why do
you mistrust your institutions we'll be
talking about that we'll also be talking
about uh Linda yaccarino she's the new
CEO going to be the new CEO at Twitter a
lot of people on the right not thrilled
I agree a lot of people on the left not
thrilled which means that uh hey maybe
that's a good thing
no no I'm kidding I'm kidding she's
awful uh and uh also are we doing that
are we talking about Miller Lite today
uh yeah I think we have that uh in there
Miller Lite said hey Bud Light hold my
beer and they decided to do an ad
condemning their entire consumer base
namely men because
why why would you drink Miller Lite beer
is what they want to know and they don't
want you drinking Miller Light beer and
I think you should listen to them yes
absolutely hold my equally crappy beer
is hold my bum piss said the CEO Miller
Lite
you know him you love him that's a CEO
number two Gerald Morgan Gerald a how
are you sir I'm well how are you I'm
good yeah I'm good Joe Lewis got messed
up by some Canadian geese so he did he's
okay by that I mean scared well I mean
he got scared those things are jerks
there were three of them and they went
full wingspan ah he's like I didn't even
want you though and he ran off they've
taken down airplanes Stephen yes they
have yes they also took out our bus when
we were driving back from Urbana
Illinois remember that crack the
windshield oh that's right the driver
next to me was listening to uh Kenny
Loggins with noise canceling headphones
at two in the morning
that is ball retractingly scary when you
wake up and look and you look over here
danger zone you're like we're gonna die
and in third chair when you hear this
music that means you know who it is
oh oh that's the stuff it's the man who
created me it's pop Crowder how are you
sir I'm great I think it's sad that you
had to explain to me that the intro was
a famous anime yes no it's more sad for
the rest of us that we know it that's
fair so uh by the way it's a live show
Monday through Friday 10 a.m Eastern you
can watch on Rumble you can listen to
the podcast that's the best way to tune
in because notifications on YouTube
don't work and by the way if you signed
up prior to May anytime within the last
12 months I know a lot of you signed up
for mug Club a while ago maybe you
didn't get your mug maybe you felt like
ah you signed up you weren't able to get
a refund and now of course we launched
this completely independently in
partnership with Rumble what you can do
is send proof of your purchase of any
right-leaning subscription service right
leading streaming service to free mug
Club at ladderwithcredit.com we will
send you three months free yeah
absolutely those emails should start
going out this week so make sure you
check your box for the promo codes and
by the way doesn't count if you signed
up for us yes it doesn't get impressive
you don't get a double free emails I've
gotten from people that signed up for us
well semantically it does that's double
dipping that's like sticking your entire
mouth in the dip
one dip it end it end it
So speaking of double dipping uh former
vice president Good Michael Pence he's
going to be in New Hampshire today to
give a speech uh in what any obviously
view as a potential launch of his he's
in he said that he is interested right
this whole thing of exploratory
committee and they set something up and
I don't know I don't want it I don't
want it all right just another slice
that's what they do so he's going to be
running for president Mike Pence and uh
that brings us to this week's time to
close
former vice president Mike Pence is
gearing up to announce for a potential
2024 presidential run a person who was
at the Capitol that day as you know was
your vice president Mike Pence who says
that you endangered his life on that day
president Trump was wrong
on January 6. time to close
endings and Beginnings are ending and
beginning now
[Music]
Mr President do you feel that you owe
him an apology no because he did
something wrong he should have put the
votes back to the state legislatures and
I think we would have had a different
outcome president Trump cut taxes across
the board you know the American people
are witnessing the strong leadership of
President Trump on the world stage
president Donald Trump is stepping in to
the role of leader of the Free World I'm
just very confident that Republican
voters will will Choose Wisely again and
I'm confident our standard Bearer will
uh
will uh
we'll carry the day if that standard
Bearer is the former president if he is
the nominee would you support him well I
think we'll have better choices and I
really trust
Republican voters to sort it out I know
[Music]
it's time for things to close
foreign
statement toward Mike Pence or just that
you're getting older well is that Mike
Pence a bit of both by the way that
moment the fly landed on his hair and he
did nothing for I guess three minutes
with a fly set up a community yes it was
the time to be lost it's not okay the
fly it said he's so comfortable yes with
the fly on him he is this is just
another Tuesday for him he's like oh
yeah it's a fly in me it's a smell of
salt he's so stilted and measured and
scripted yeah I'll pause here I'll grin
yes then I'll look to the side and I'll
throw something out yeah just go away go
also he needs stilts
no Trump destroyed it why does my pen
sound like Casey Casey
announcing my exploratory committee tap
40 love songs with Casey Kasem it is
Mike Pence's presidential campaign the
stick your head in the oven tap 40
announcements what's the name of the guy
from Kentucky who was just on scene on
this morning who's announced uh he's
running for president I haven't was he
governor was he senator of Kentucky you
guys can bring up that name he was
sitting there talking on CNN he's like
well I think what Americans want is the
uh to focus on you know lowering the
debt and look there's nothing wrong with
that but these people do not understand
how to speak to the American public yeah
Mike Pence he's just he's a super douche
well but he's actually he's getting
ahead of the game a little bit and so he
actually announced his vice presidential
candidate to make sure that there was
more energy uh Ben Carson yes oh yes the
guy you're thinking of was ASA
Hutchinson ASA Hudson Arkansas what did
I say you said Kentucky oh okay sorry
Kentucky Arkansas
similar but not really is he the one
that Sarah Huckabee beat
so all these people look look I get it
we need a robust primary but we don't
need people who don't have a chance this
is about them raising some money and
doing a book tour eventually this is a
problem with politics Mike Pence needs
to go away why because he sucks
all right now we'll move on hit like if
you agree by the way because the YouTube
algorithm doesn't give a rat's ass about
anything so they don't give a rat's ass
if you're subscribed so you hit like you
share it and by the way if at any point
today while you're watching on YouTube
you see and hear this
that means head on over to rumble we're
not going to self-censor uh speaking of
people who should sell sensor did you
watch this pops cried or the Miller Lite
uh yeah yeah you did I did yeah
seething rage well I don't think men
should drink Miller Light anyways yes
that's a good point that's a good point
so they're not men they're not men
that's a little macchiato peers
so Miller Lite told Bud Light to hold
its beer now this this was uh actually
something that was released in March to
be clear but it's making the rounds now
because they actually deleted it they
deleted it on Instagram and so someone
found it and it resurfaced which tells
you the kind of reaction that they got
yeah and uh this is Miller Lite
designing to burn their customer base to
the ground and by the way also entirely
factually inaccurate so we'll fact check
it really quickly just so you can kind
of have justification for the it's you
look if you're watching this you're a
Christian it's wrong to hate unless you
hate the right things and Miller Lite
qualifies here's a little known fact
women were among the very first to brew
beer ever oh a month how do you know
colonial America women were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later
throughout the industry to the founding
mothers of beer they put us in bikinis
founding mothers of year
oh because that's offensive yeah we put
them in yeah
we just noticed
Miller Light has been scouring the
internet for all this no is that a trans
woman
for women Brewers literally
how you ask ladies take it away first we
turn the batch into a compost then we
feed compost to warm zip it out
beautiful fertilizer
you notice that they give her a smaller
fertilizer
Brewers to make their own really good
it's definitely more down there in your
attic in the garage in your parents
basement send anything you got into
Miller Lite and they'll turn that into
good too
[Music]
so here's to women because without us
there would be no fears well without
people like you there'd be no reason for
beer
not us there'll be no miller yes exactly
remember everybody March was women's
revisionary history month just to be
clearly so
that last claim without us there would
be no beer you said among yeah exactly
we were among the first Brewers which
means you watched and you said hey why
are you spending all day Brewing why
don't you come home and talk to me what
are you thinking
she meant amongst amongst yes apparently
there were others that could have done
this yeah yeah sorry you know what
sometimes you think hey maybe AI taking
over half the jobs is a good thing we
deserve it yeah
and Forbes and we're going to factor
nearly everything she just said is
incorrect by the way this is the problem
is the rewriting of History I get it I
get it you don't like white men okay we
understand it but you're wrong you're
just incorrect now Forbes praised the ad
with an article title titled Miller
lights campaign to eradicate sexist beer
advertising proof successful sexist B
first off I don't know how beer can be
sexist I know they're saying advertising
tomorrow we actually will have our very
own um Mr Miller the sexist beer yeah
okay uh to we conduct an interview yeah
but it proves successful so successful
they had to delete it
own social media
the minute Dylan Mulvaney started
gracing a Bud Light they're like oh god
oh
gosh
sales are taking they were watching the
Dylan Mulvaney debacle unfurl like every
single scientist who wasn't listened to
before every Disaster Movie like
watching the stage five the level five
hurricane like oh my gosh you know I had
never had a Carl's Jr until Paris Hilton
so it works
that says more about you
absolutely it's a terrible wish I want a
hamburger right now and a terrible
person yes so by the way here let's go
through the claim and then some rapid
fire so the claim that she makes uh is
from Mesopotamia to colonial America
women were the ones doing the Brewing
okay here are some truths uh
no okay now some women have been
involved to be certain just like women
are involved with a lot of things but
men throughout history have largely been
the ones brewing beer now if you mean
that some woman at some point found
something that happened to be fermented
and like took a nibble thing ah try it
and the guy was like I have my own
fermented wheat and you should think try
mine maybe
it's got peaches but men have been
Brewing beers throughout history so
let's go to 1265 Bohemian king
um auto car hopefully I have that right
Odo car the second Charter Brewery in
the town of budweis originally uh you
know that's the home of of Budweiser
right the origin I should say George
Washington Thomas Jefferson they had
breweries on their own plantations uh
and women didn't actually do a lot of
the Brewing just to be clear the
widespread Brewing appear it was present
by uh uh what was present in ancient
Egypt and was presided over by men just
to be clear
and then before you had this sort of
mechanization right the sort of
Industrial Revolution planting
harvesting of course uh was what a lot
of the men did so maybe what they mean
to say is that sometimes the men would
do all of the legwork and then they take
and then like yeah you go out and do you
go out with the Scythe in the sun before
we have SPF anything and uh you bring it
and I'll stir the pot of the wart every
now and then and then I'm the Brewer I'm
the brewmaster
I Mrs Old Milwaukee
no men did most of the physically
exhaustive tasks that of course will be
required to create beer here's just a
clip because
Farmers used a simple Scythe to harvest
their grain they could cut an acre a day
then they had to thresh it an average
Farm was small and it fed about five
people and he did not come home to a
woman who took credit
you know why don't you just like maybe
you should use it like this you know
it's more of a risk like maybe shut up
he had dinner waiting for him yes
exactly 73 of American farmers today are
men just to be clear men were paid in
beer because so British Navy sailors
they receive a daily ration of beer
until the 1810s Belgian farmhands were
actually paid in what uh is commonly
referred to now as Cezanne beer some
people call it Farmhouse beer but Cesar
means season right in French because
it's like the season of the Harvest they
would pay their work hands because it
was safer than water back then and again
most of the work hands were men and it's
liquid bread yes serves a good purpose
well it's actually if it's low ABV beer
it's not actually a bad idea uh and in
place of like a Gatorade there are
electrolytes you have potassium a little
bit of salt in there high source of
silicone beer can be helpful in
moderation again people will get mad who
don't drink I understand and if you
don't drink you don't have to start
drinking I'm just telling you that men
brewed the beer and men were the
farmhands who got all the materials that
were used to brew the beer by the way
smash the rumble button if you're
watching on Rumble because that's the
only place where this is allowed uh
exactly I mean I could talk about this
on YouTube they'll just Shadow ban it
here's something else the monks just to
be clear they were involved with beer
production monks I don't know if you
know this monks monks monks I mean men
the Belgian Travis monks they brewed
beer to sustain themselves during
fasting which by the way makes fasting a
whole lot easier if you can drink
Belgian ales pretty clear even though
you're instantly hammered have you had
any West Mall or Tre they're like nine
eleven percent yes about an empty
stomach what are you doing I'm yeah I'm
just communing with the Lord the Daniel
Fast is so much easier yes I find that
I'm brought much much closer to Jesus
after four Belgian triples with no food
on my stomach
I'm fasting
yeah Catholic saints like Saint Arnold
uh of course when we had St Florian they
saved people with uh with beer they
would use it they would also commune
amongst people and then uh by the way
the nuns only brought Zima so that was
something
now let's look at the demographic the
Brewers they cater to their core
demographic men prefer beer to women
according to a Gallup poll men 54 women
23 also it's a big gap worth noting over
time that without women there would be
no beer
okay uh I don't know if you know this
but some of the inventions some of the
uh devices that have been used that have
been implemented to brew beer can I
mechanize Harvesters pasteurization kegs
Taps all of those were invented by men
there you go so the men went up to the
field they took and this is why women
just so you know it's not the Trap there
are things that women do better than men
working as a farmhand and brewing beer
on Modern inventions Chris is not Chief
amongst them just to be clear this is
why people get upset it is about and
this is the issue too we'll talk about
this with a Twitter CEO they aren't
beholden to their user base this is what
happened right with Budweisers the sales
went down or Bud Light right the stock
went up for a little bit why because
it's about their shareholders it's about
the board it's about the ESG score it's
about Black Rock it's about Vanguard
it's about International interest it's
not about the actual people who consume
the beer and the left just takes history
and then says the opposite of it yeah
but who invented the bikini well it's
probably a guy yeah probably I mean
that's the reason thing a little bit but
also by Miller Lite also tampons and
birth control just to be clear and we
did that for you okay those were kind of
for us a little bit
I don't know why a guy invented
pantyhose before that every woman wore
garter belts
then we decided to make we decided no
we're gonna make this far less
attractive into Stephen right there
what is that I have no idea what
someone's bringing up your back this is
personal all right anything else that I
missed no I don't think look they could
have just sent out an ad that said hey
we want to honor the contributions of
women sure in brewing beer fantastic yes
but in real defense I think she meant it
was a question as a question she she
said uh Mesopotamia Mesopotamia so I
think she started out with that at the
very top Mesopotamia and then the entire
industry has like beholden to that
advertising since infancy essentially
yes and now you're going to go back and
say ah we're so wrong for doing this to
you and I'm like no do you know how much
money those people got paid this is what
it is it is
this is how how you know it is so
clearly and I would love to you guys can
comment below it used to be the Pearl
clutching you know Republicans right
people who would like that's
inappropriate until and by the way
usually Christians just were saying hey
that's age inappropriate for kids right
we need a rating system like rated R
South Park for example shouldn't be on
at uh nine o'clock at night when kids
tune into a cartoon right that might
have been the issue but now the left is
the there the Pearl clutches who are
offended by everything they're going oh
bikinis we're just saying like hey hold
on a second maybe you shouldn't have
nc17 like 12 year olds going up at the
left now is offended at the
sexualization of women and by the way
there's a limit to it but here's the
thing look men like beer men like
beautiful women you put beautiful women
in bikinis next to beer the product
sells itself
look it's terrible beer they're offended
by everything but under what basis I
thought sexuality was empowering oh
unless it's women who don't look like
you namely attractive women who help
sell beer
to the monks well no they're not
advertising to the monks I don't think
they have televisions they make their
own beer they have a lot of beer that's
true they made the best beer by the way
yeah they do they make the best beer the
monks but the left is a religion they're
offended now they're the ones saying you
have to get rid of a bikini that's
inappropriate really what they're
offended by is beauty yes take lizzo and
put her in a bikini and it's beautiful
and it's Brave take an attractive woman
and put her next to an American icon in
a company and you go oh a second that's
that's wrong that's wrong you're
sexualizing women do you think that do
you think that if you take an attractive
woman and put it in a turtleneck that
men still aren't thinking the same thing
you're just skipping the intermediate
step
by the way they also have no problem
with a trans person in a thong
performing before children yes well
that's beautiful and brave well that's
the right sexualization the wrong
sexualization is Kathy Ireland
Natural Women yeah you
we swapped out uh Hal McPherson for
RuPaul
the fall of Rome folks you're living it
so
Now we move on to the term investigation
it's just people watch it you know that
you're mad there you go all the
references are made publicly available
at ladder with credit.com the link is in
the description what she said is
incorrect I'm sure there were a few
women nagging at the Brewers somewhere
down the line so okay it's the same
partnership
[Laughter]
all right let's go to this uh the Durham
investigation again this was the probe
right wow the special counsel Durham
released finally the report on the FBI's
2016 Trump Russia wait I'm always
surprised when this story comes back
because I thought it was done we it just
it seems like it's confirming what we
knew and to be clear they have admitted
now just so just so you know I'm front
loading this and we'll get into the fact
checking they've attributed everything
that was wrong and by everything I do
mean everything that's not hyperbole to
missteps that's that's the word of the
day
[Laughter]
I like the silly I just don't
participate
[Laughter]
above it I don't do a good Pee-wee
Herman no no one does a good PeeWee
Herman
stop it
that was bad and you should feel bad all
right
let's run the clip the argument that
John Durham is making here is an
argument that he's made before which is
essentially that he doesn't believe the
FBI had the proper predication was fully
justified in opening that
counter-intelligence investigation code
name Crossfire hurricane back in 2016
into the Trump campaign he says that the
FBI acted hastily and on uncorroborated
raw information and he says that the
there was other information for example
the government that wanted to try to
influence them that the FBI didn't react
to in similar ways
okay so this is what the the missteps by
the way is using the FBI's Twitter
response saying
you said it had these reforms been in
the play been in place in 2016 the
missteps identified
you need a moratorium on the word of the
day or uh
the word of the day identified in the
report could have been prevented and by
the way reforms mean any type of
guidelines or standards whatsoever and
this just to be clear now it's
irrefutable we've known this for a long
time but now the FBI is completely
admitting it Durham is admitting it yes
this constitutes an actual war on
Democracy when you have your own
intelligence institutions the Bible it
has happened in the past of course when
you have federal agents who are plotting
to kidnap a governor and blame it on
some glorified beer drinking Club when
they decide to actively commit crimes on
January 6 going into the capital in
order to entrap other people though it's
not just entrapment because an
entrapment you're not actually allowed
to commit a crime as a federal agent yes
that is a war on Democracy that is a war
against you the American citizen just to
be clear this is just more confirmation
of that why don't you trust your
Institution
foreign
[Music]
Durham said look I don't think there
should have been a full-scale
investigation but a preliminary
investigation wouldn't that have led to
a full-scale investigation because if
you look at some of the connections that
would have prompted the FBI to say hey
we need to look into this fully exactly
I mean that's a big admission on
Durham's part the fact that he conceded
that a preliminary investigation was
appropriate to to start and by the way
you're exactly right it wouldn't come
back converted into a full investigation
anyway it doesn't take a lot to get
there for the FBI and they immediately
started uncovering all of these
questionable contacts between the
Russians and the Trump folks I mean
there was a lot of them no why do they
even say that no they've admitted that
that's not the case Jared let's go to
your point because then we have some
then and now clicks this is them really
trying to couch it we have some clips
from CNN actually acknowledging that
this was a shame but you had here's
here's the low-level investigation that
it should have been and they said that
this should have been a preliminary low
level happens all the time nobody finds
out about it like now it doesn't make
any sense at all that should have been
the low-level investigation no it would
not have blown up into a full-scale
investigation the problem that we have
is that you guys want to act like a
handful of people on January 6 was
overthrowing democracy because they got
out of control not the rest of the
protesters that weren't getting out of
control but the people that handful
maybe a few hundred people yeah that
ended up getting crazy out of a crowd of
literally tens and tens and tens of
hundreds of thousands of people maybe
hundreds of thousands of people there
right this is the government actively
going after the sitting president of the
United States
for three years and by the way saying
that the election was not legitimate
just to be clear yes claiming the
election was not legitimate that
Russians were absolutely influencing the
president United States dogging him at
every single turn this is not a mistake
this is not an oopsie and by the way
it's still to this day people go oh bro
Donald Trump Putin's puppet because of
this yes the preliminary investigation
sometimes people will give you crap if
you're being reductive I think it's
distilling it you know my my favorite
community of all time Norm McDonald
we've talked about he would take a punch
line he would take a joke and he would
distill it down to as few words as
possible that's what the preliminary
investigation should have been it should
have been yeah
it's paid for by Hillary Clinton you
know yeah yeah they can't use that
that's uh sounds of just you
know there Hillary Clinton and the
Dashie not reliable source in other news
that has been killed again yeah it has
been killed again
that's exactly what it should have been
this is this should scare the hell out
of everybody because this is not
somebody just not following practices
like the FBI Suites said oh we've we've
got new things in place it was a
political hit job you guys tried to take
down a sitting president knowing that it
was false somebody it changes everything
for that it changes everything like I've
said they created unwittingly created
the most squeaky clean presidency ever
the way they scrutinized him every
single day and he could he can deny
anything now he's totally insulated why
would we why would we believe you ever
no yeah I mean this is a big win for him
yeah exactly he's like well look this is
sexually abused her but you said that I
worked with Russia so sorry
doesn't matter what it is and we can
skip Cliff MSNBC because we're just
talking about on CNN this is them now
trying to downplay it but the findings
are so conclusive again all references
are publicly available that even CNN
has not been able to actually deny their
their their actuality regardless the
report is now here it has dropped and it
might not have produced everything of
what some Republicans vote for it is
regardless devastating to the FBI and to
a degree it does exonerate Donald Trump
the investigation
that the FBI failed in many many ways
and by the way what does that mean they
failed at what they failed at trying to
remove a sitting president by what
sowing mistrust in the legitimacy of the
election there was an entire board
Council Elizabeth Warren was on there
Amy Klobuchar saying we need to
strengthen our elections because Russia
interfered with the 2016 election just
like fake news the left tried to use
fake news initially and then Donald
Trump jujitsued it on him now they hate
that term fake news they were the ones
saying elections are not fair elections
are not free elections are being
interfered with foreign entities that we
have people here in the United States
namely Donald Trump working with foreign
entities foreign agents no word on the
fact that Eric swalwell was fornicating
a Chinese why
which brings us to this installment of
then and now
[Music]
all right so let's go back to then right
then time travel time travel
they said that there was ample evidence
so much evidence they could just kind of
skip the preliminary oh yeah yeah uh to
open what was referred to if you have
forgotten it was referred to as
Crossfire hurricane that was the
investigation good naming back then on
Capitol Hill today lawmakers were busy
pouring over the election we just had
I'm honored to be here representing the
people of the FBI members of the House
intelligence committee convening a
blockbuster hearing I would like to
welcome our Witnesses director of the
FBI Jim Comey and director of the
National Security Agency Admiral Rogers
the nation's top cop and one of the
nation's most senior spymasters there to
testify about allegations that Russia
tried to influence the outcome I have
been authorized by the Department of
Justice to confirm that the FBI as part
of our counterintelligence mission is
investigating the Russian government's
efforts to interfere in the 2016
presidential election now why would you
need to know that they were
investigating again theater this was a
show investigation a show sort of
pseudo-trial really because Donald
Trump's character was put on trial so
that was then now and this is according
to the Durham report
um there was I know what you're thinking
some none
am I little maybe little not even any
really
no smidgen there was no credible
evidence this is from the report based
on the evidence gathered in the multiple
exhaustive and costly Federal
investigations neither U.S law
enforcement nor the intelligence
Community appears to have possessed any
actual evidence of collusion in their
Holdings at the commencement of the
crossfire hurricane investigation and
just what you're saying no credible
evidence you're saying well hold on a
second what's the standard well Durham
noted that the FBI did not for example
interview any pertinent Witnesses
they didn't review their own
intelligence and they didn't use any
standard analytical tools that will be
used in an investigation like this yes
so no evidence none whatsoever this has
been going on for years by the way
continued remember the questions for
Donald Trump in the re-election campaign
were still about Russia yeah absolutely
by the way they if they had just looked
at kind of the top sheet for the binder
and it said Hillary Clinton campaign
strategy that probably would have tipped
them off just a little bit uh also the
timing in October for the October
surprise I think that was uh well no one
reason top sheet anymore well they need
to really touch you so listen this is
James Comey right the guy who tried to
rehab I think it was on HBO or one of
those places tried to rehab His Image by
doing this documentary releasing a book
he's the guy who found that Hillary
Clinton had all of the information that
we thought she had on her private emails
you know all the email stuff that was
classified yeah on her private servers
at home and deleted them and destroyed
the information so that we couldn't even
go into it right use bleach bit or
whatever it was to kind of get rid of it
and said Ah that's that's not good but I
don't think we should a charger yeah
that's that guy hey if they weren't
spending again according to the uh
according to the report here the
exhaustive and costly if they weren't
spending those resources maybe we could
have found out uh all the people who
were sex trafficked to Epstein's
pedophile Island probably so and it
wouldn't cost you much you just have to
ask just like Maxwell she's she's in
jail we we know where she is you just
walk to the island like Colombo with a
notepad and you say you have sex with
Epstein and the answer is always yes it
is always yes yes and then you'd be able
to find it still no answers the Vegas
shooter nothing but they spent a bunch
of time on this and by the way it's not
that they didn't find anything they were
fabricating information to the public
that the media of course disseminated
all right so let's go back to then right
in fact then they were claiming that the
steel dossier and you remember steel
dossier Fusion GPS was paid for by
partially by the Hillary Clinton
campaign they were saying back then that
the steel dossier was completely
legitimate well Jake for the first time
U.S investigators say that they have
corroborated some of the communications
detailed in a 35-page dossier compiled
by a former British intelligence agent
CNN was first to report last month that
then president-elect Donald Trump and
President Obama were briefed on the
existence of the memos he's been in
office two three weeks at that point
right U.S officials have said that none
of the content or allegations have been
verified but now multiple current and
former U.S law enforcement and
intelligence officials tell CNN that
intelligence intercepts of foreign
Nationals confirmed that some of the
conversations described in the dossier
took place between the same individuals
on the same days and from the same
locations as detailed in the dossier
this is why I believe sometimes people
say oh it's being reductive this is why
beliefs in speaking as clearly as
possible okay you should be simple and
clear in your communication what that
man just said was nothing
yes so we're trying to paint a picture
so you can hold the media account not
just the media but of course the DNC but
I repeat myself hold them accountable
that's what they were saying back then
though they haven't been corroborated
now they're saying that they have right
that's what they said back then this
brings us to now no the FBI didn't
corroborate anything according to the
report the FBI attempted over time to
investigate and analyze the steel
reports But ultimately was not able to
confirm or corroborate any of the
substantive allegations contained in
those reports nothing that's insane the
guy basically just at CNN fire Everyone
by the way all of your advisors all of
the multiple intelligence agency people
plus former intelligence officials that
said this what was it at a time there
was like 60 some odd people that they
kept what like some number that they
kept quoting like yeah according to 60
Former Intelligence former and current
that this is true fire every single one
of them and actually do your damn job as
a journalist maybe go out and find out
what confirm one I actually think that
this is one of those issues where as a
matter of National Security this entire
investigation should be unsealed we
should know how they interview people we
should know how they tried to
corroborate their sources we should know
how they investigated these in other
words how do you spend this much time in
these many resources I understand that
sometimes in the interest of national
security for example if you're trying to
track down some Jihadi in the middle of
you know what you're soon to turn into
kellel's bachelor pad then yeah okay you
need to keep that hidden in this case we
now know that it was a sham we want to
know hold on a second why did it take
you this long and what leads were you
tracking down what leads were you
chasing down comment below and hit like
if you think this should be released to
the public not just the final report not
just a briefing but everything this
should be the kind of scenario where
investigative journalists you citizen
journalists should be able to dive deep
into this you should be able to comb
through all of it to see what
[Music]
thank you my name is Igor danchenko who
was a Russian national
and described himself uh we just treated
Russian national and uh he described his
own sources as rumor and speculation
[Music]
Igor the Russian equivalent of TMZ yes
exactly tonight
I see Trump at airport oh did you sleep
with Chinese spy he's peeing on
prostitutes too don't don't forget that
was part of this report no he had
prostitutes peeing on furniture in front
of him remember that's an in-depth
Supply yes it is
it makes no sense because he's a
germaphobe
if Donald Trump was into weird sex if
the last thing I would assume would be
Russian prostitutes paying on furniture
I don't know is it me like maybe he
would be into watching Russian press
like in a maid outfit cleaning up
Furniture like that it's even
though it has a it has a cellophane
clear
[Laughter]
WetJet I love the wet chat
big fan so this brings us back to then
and again they want to memory hold this
they want to Gaslight you so now you're
like well I guess so well they did they
did their investigation or no they were
already telling you the conclusion of
the investigation as it was ongoing and
it was being dishonestly conducted they
said back then that this was an unbiased
investigation in light of the Don Jr
email and other allegations that this
whole thing about Trump campaign in
Russia is a Witch Hunt
is that a fair description of what we're
all dealing with in America
well Senator I can't speak to the basis
for those comments I can tell you that
my experience with directions I'm asking
you as the future FBI director you
consider this endeavor a Witch Hunt
I did not consider director Mueller to
be on a Witch Hunt okay now I understand
that's a term that maybe if it exists
sort of in a vacuum Witch Hunt all right
do we have anything to compare it to
which brings us to
now now we know that there were
different standards double standards if
you will use to investigate Trump while
ignoring Hillary Clinton so this is from
the report unlike the FBI's opening of a
full investigation of unknown members of
the Trump campaign based on raw
uncorroborated information in this
separate matter involving purported
Hillary Clinton campaign plan the FBI
never opened any type of inquiry hmm
that's several steps removed from an
entirely conduct investigation we didn't
have a preliminary investigation we
spent Federal resources on the
investigation not even an inquiry with
Hillary Clinton even though she said
yeah I did that
pretty much they they knew this by the
way Barack Obama knew this they're in
yes you look at some of the reports in
this uh this kind of the Durham report
if you look at this then and maybe our
research team can pull this up they
actually briefed I think Brennan uh
briefed the president about this and
about this being something from the
Hillary Clinton campaign kind of as the
origination of the source I believe that
that was known at the time of course
that that was and they briefed him in
the situation room yeah right this this
is like everybody was in on it guys
everybody was in on it that's what it
tells you the sitting president of the
United States the person who is the
front runner for the Democrats the CIA
and the FBI were in on it yeah they knew
about this the entire time and went out
and said well several sources tell us
that this is true several sources tell
us former and and current intelligence
officials tell us that this is true in
Russia's meddling meddling in the
election before his boxes are even
unpacked at 1600 Pennsylvania this is in
the news right exactly and then they
would ask me remember when they fact
checked him at one said in the you know
the previous administration spied on my
Camp they said that's not true Mr
President it absolutely was true yeah
yeah it absolutely was true
foreign
[Music]
policy advisor to vilify Donald Trump by
stirring up a scandal claiming
interference by Russian Security
Services there it is oh July of 2016. he
knew he didn't Everyone likes to act
like Barack Obama is a stand-up guy no
no no no no no no no no no wait okay
hold on I can't think straight no isn't
that illegal uh
effectively tarnish spy on a campaign
yeah
unprecedent even though we know it's
illegal uh that's correct Mr President
yes
pull that back up I want to be clear
this is not that this was an allegation
this is not that this was some kind of
thing where we're saying July 26 2016 a
proposal from one of her foreign policy
advisors to vilify Donald Trump by
stirring up a scandal claiming
interference by Russian Security
Services
approved by Hillary Clinton that's the
conversation that they had not hey
there's this dossier and yeah part of
it's funded by these guys but we still
think it's true no no no this was a plot
cooked up by Hillary Clinton Mr
President and we want you to know about
it so everybody's on the same page when
we go out in public and make sure that
everybody hears about it don't get old
we
keep going
so so here's here's the other thing
about this it's no charges right no
charges right now from this report I
think we've pulled up in the past maybe
Hillary Clinton's lawyer one time was
charged for something and and was
acquitted there may have been one person
that actually was convicted of something
but they're looking at this right now
and saying oh but at least you know
there's no breaking of the law but hey
remember nobody's Above the Law so
Donald Trump you know I know you're
being you know in New York right now
you're being indicted and actually a
trial is coming up about something where
you didn't actually pay somebody because
they said you didn't pay them for this
but your lawyer is lying about this
right now because he spent some time in
jail but there's no charges for this
yeah this is the biggest sedition case
in the history of this country arguably
maybe there's one more I'm forgetting
about that should be tried and if the
Congress does not take up hearings
immediately on this yeah they are not
doing their job by the way this is the
this is the information equivalent of
disarming you as a populist in other
words if you don't have the ability to
defend yourself if you don't have a
firearm and only the government has
Firearms well it's no longer a fair
fight right you might as well just
submit to their will if the government
is not beholden to the law in other
words if you can be charged if you can
be convicted for the exact same crimes
for which they will be entirely absolved
at every turn you no longer have a free
Society the intelligence agencies are
supposed to exist to serve and protect
you they don't they protect themselves
why do you mistrust your institutions I
think if you trusted our institutions in
2023 I think you're a fool this was an
actual subversion of democracy it was a
thousand times worse than what happened
on January 6th just to be clear uh and
well maybe not if you're including what
the FBI did on January 6th but the point
remains and by the way again the
intelligence agencies what's important
they work for three years three years
three years in collusion with Democrats
in collusion with before Donald Trump
came to office then sitting president
and the person they thought was going to
have a coronation Hillary Clinton to try
and prevent and then unseat
the president you elected and they chalk
it all up now
I don't know how many millions of
dollars I'd be interested to see those
numbers they Chuck it all up to oh is
this there's just a few missteps
I'm done with it do you buy it do you
buy it that was low energy comment below
do you buy them do you buy the just oh
it was a mistake
they forgot I forget that's they have
the Lloyd Christmas defense I forgot you
never make a mistake yeah exactly yes
people should be going to jail sorry
this is not a mistake this is this is
the
if this is allowed to continue
don't don't think for a second that the
FBI and the CIA won't be weaponized
potentially the other way or just
potentially against everyday citizens I
don't know like the IRS has been in the
past you remember when that happened
when all the conservatives started
getting audited for no reason whatsoever
by the IRS and they started coming and
closing down businesses don't think for
a second that this can be let's go
through the Donald Trump indictments
right when you say go to jail because
that's important it's pretty severe okay
Donald Trump okay do you think Donald
Trump should go to jail for uh calling a
porn star a lying
do you think you said you think that's a
jailable offense when she admitted that
it never happened then said it did
happen then said it didn't happen then
said that it did happen and by the way
she lost to the point where she has to
pay his legal okay is that a jailable
offense is it a jailable offense to say
that woman's not my type where he was
not found guilty of actually raping
somebody is it a jailable offense should
he go to jail when you talk about
January 6th but they discussed that he
said make your voices patriotically and
peacefully heard is it a jailable
offense to say this is not a free
election this is rigged is that jailable
here's the thing for everything you
dislike about Donald Trump there is
something valuable and someone never
able to shut up he's not capable of
Keeping a Secret
you know there weren't things done in
Secrets because
he's publicly
phone call he's like what do you mean it
was a perfect call deny the call it's a
perfect call it was the best call you go
make the call I bet it would shut
are those jailable now is it should it
be a jailable offense to clear
classified information from your
computer and collude by the way with the
media with intelligence agencies to try
and overthrow a democratic election
and it's elected leader Donald Trump
what's a jailable offense comment below
I'm very curious let's take the worst
that they throw at Donald Trump
I don't even think it's close I don't
even think it's close I'd also like to
start a call for the Washington Post to
give back their Pulitzer for their
coverage of the 2016 Russia Scandal
right is it time for you guys to do that
because you got an award yeah that's
right
maybe call it sir
I'm crying out loud that's like that's
like the Nobel Peace Prize no one wants
that anymore you know somebody's got to
be spanked for this that this has to
have some teeth yes and then we need to
start going after these guys hard I mean
legally not the way they fight but we
need to start you know when we get the
power back we need to start taking their
guys down that's just the way it is and
this is the thing until someone Taps
it's got to be hard if Ronda Santos
doesn't come out and say defund the FBI
completely remember I asked Carrie like
I said that is my if if the candidate
for our I should say in the primaries I
won't vote for anyone who does not
espouse the belief of defunding the FBI
and the CIA and building something else
in this place they want you to think
that you're an extremist what's the
value in the FBI what's the value in the
CIA when you see this how did everybody
let's assume incompetence as opposed to
malicious intent which we know now right
how incompetent does every single person
in the FBI have to be for this to go on
well I I guess about the about the time
of the presidential term right time of
re-election that's about how long it
went on and then it sort of fizzled into
the background if it's that if it's that
completely incompetent then there's no
value there do you find the FBI defund
the FBI and the CIA we need something
else in its place or nothing would be
just as good at this point right they
didn't come out and issue an apology
either they didn't come out and say
Donald Trump actually was not guilty it
took an investigation into what happened
by the federal government to see this
yeah that
and Donald Trump will not get anything
from this he will not other than a giant
bump in the polls right right and one
more thing to point at but and being
inoculated sorry that inoculation is
worth a lot if I'm him I go to that well
[Music]
I hope that I'm getting that right it's
close enough and uh this has upset
people on the right it's upset some
people on the left namely people on the
right but this is an issue we talked
about this with Tucker Carlson and we're
pretty fortunate here in our partnership
um with with Rumble
um
who is more important
The Advertiser and by the way giant
multinational conglomerate right
corporations who have ESG and woke
scores uh or you or the user and that is
going to determine the direction of
Twitter that's one thing that we have
we're incredibly Grateful by the way you
can join up at latroscrediter.com we are
actually funded by viewers like you it's
89 annual did you say that we have a
discount now for veterans we I need to
put the code in place but it should be
there about the next week we're gonna
have the code for the next week for for
veterans or active military uh you don't
join up there's no more show you see
sponsors every now and then there will
never be more than one per show and
these are sponsors that are basically
boycott proof
but this is the issue we saw with Tucker
Carlson Fox News said hey we're going
with the advertisers who by the way are
not beholden to the audience you see it
with Bud Light you see it with Miller
they're not actually really I guess I
should say mentally uh preoccupied with
the idea of you the user base the
consumer they say oh it's like it's
about the dollars it's about the board
it's about the shares and this is going
to determine the direction of Twitter
who's more important The Advertiser and
that's what I see which is most
troubling not just the leftist
Tendencies or you the user
um so let's kind of get uh get through
there you go
March uh 23 just to be clear they're
appointing a new CEO for a few different
reasons Tesla stock has been sort of
waning a little bit it requires more
attention from Elon Musk part of me
thinks this was a Billionaire's toy
train set and he sort of got bored of it
now the revenue at Twitter and this is
the difference between the revenue
versus people using Twitter the revenue
at Twitter fell about 50 because of a
massive decline in ad Revenue just to be
clear now that is because a lot of woke
companies have said we don't we're not
going to advertise on Twitter now that
doesn't necessarily correlate with the
success of Twitter as a platform which
was its original intent right to be a
place where people could communicate
because musk has actually talked about
this new Twitter sign ups have been at
an all-time high yeah right they were up
66 percent per day from 2021 to uh 2022
from November 21 to 20. legit hockey
stick graph yeah 66 per day now we don't
have the full numbers on the
interactions the daily traffic but the
point is their shirt the 50 decline in
advertising
does not match the intent of Twitter
which is to be an open form so if
advertisers are saying yeah we don't
want to advertise in a place that's an
open form of ideas that doesn't censor
people who encourages freedom of speech
well now you have a decision to make
tell the advertisers to go screw
themselves kind of like us with Google
with YouTube We Don't the only time you
ever see random ads if you're watching
on YouTube is because someone else has
claimed our content right the Google
AdSense we don't make a dollar yeah we
decided that we would not be beholden to
YouTube alphabet Facebook right
Instagram at one point Twitter and some
people decide that that's the business
model they want just on the left and on
the right what matters to us is you and
Twitter has a fork on the road is it you
the user who has determined its
direction and I would say in a largely
positive way or is it the corporations
who've decided to uh decided to cut Bing
run so yeah absolutely and by the way
some of those ad dollars will come back
because of course a lot of people right
now have been talking about how
effective advertising is especially
conservatives that we've talked to have
said hey advertising is actually pretty
effective right now on Twitter they're
actually doing a good job of making some
of those corrections but this is I think
a misstep by Elon so we'll get into some
of the details why but you'll you'll see
very quickly how this can go off well
they'll come back because of the growing
subscriber base yeah that's that's what
that's where eyeballs are that's right
yeah yeah and eventually their morals
won't matter to them because they
started in the first place yes their
morals I mean their sacrifices to mullik
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh prior to
being named Twitter's new CEO Yak Arena
let's give you a little bit of a profile
here
she was the chairman of global
advertising and Partnerships at NBC
Universal by the way we've had a few
run-ins with NBC Universal ourselves
could that conservative Bastion yes and
according to the Wall Street Journal
Miss yakarino has a reputation for hard
nose negotiating tactics and media
buyers have described her as quote the
velvet hammer velvet hammer which I
actually think was Paul Pelosi's
nickname at the nudist colony in
Sausalito so it seems like it all comes
back
a little name tag there on the hair and
they're going to switch the name of
Twitter to Bud Light so
why are people on the right uh concern
all right well there are a few reasons
so here's a major complaint that I would
say is valid yeah yeah kind of a big
kind of a biggie yakarino serves as the
executive chairman for the task force on
future of work at the world economic
Forum whoops which people do uh
typically speaking when it comes to
economic forms I don't like the world
one no no no is that the Klaus Schwab
economic world yes
oh yeah not a big
but that's just an offices by the way
will be made publicly available that one
is uh her LinkedIn so you know you can
question that if you want but maybe
she's just lying it's not honorary it's
uh active I mean I patted my resume when
I was a kid yeah you didn't put World
economic Forum I got to work at the
French Canadian version of Nordstroms
and they said you've worked in retail
before and I said
[Laughter]
forgotten the world economic Forum uh
they're the ones responsible for this
what they viewed as a positive uh I
guess sort of advert I don't know if
it's an advertisement but they put this
out there this is their dystopian Vision
uh for the future
this is real agenda 2030.
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
whatever you want you'll rent and it'll
be delivered by drone so hold on a
second
this is my problem with again the world
economic form does nobody own anything
oh no wait eventually someone owns
something you want it Consolidated to a
few Mega Powers namely government and
the corporations they deem too big to
fail it's the elites they get to own
everything and you'll rent everything
yes because you don't need to own stuff
you'll be happier trust will be happier
less stress yes the stress of chores now
listen I like the drone delivery
component of that but that is all I
don't like the drunk delivery I do I
don't at all I get ice cream delivered
every once in a while I love your
shotgun practice kids love it you really
do yes
it's a test service we need to admire on
Modest Geralds Gerald stop with the
Drone service okay it's unnecessary it's
fun guys I'm gay I am not so yakarino
also different way of getting it to your
porch nothing special stupid
kids like it but it's cool yeah videos
well you're an adult you're an adult man
[Laughter]
Jack Arena by the way also LED an ad
Council uh and this this Ad Council they
had a campaign featuring the Pope
and by the way when I'm looking to take
uh coveted vaccine advice
I look to the Pope
[Music]
still waiting for that statement on the
uh
the kid sex now the pope was wrong what
about the infallibility Gerald your
thoughts uh it's only once being on
issues of spirituality and only when
speaking ex cathedra because that's
somewhere in the back of the Bible
somewhere near the back yeah what about
the two popes that we're competing are
the popes that were purchased here's my
look and by the way I know that a lot of
Catholics out there obviously don't like
the current pope just to be clear right
yeah but at a certain point you have to
say when the pope is wrong about almost
everything else I know what you're gonna
say this is a media headship no no no no
no it's not no it's not he's been wrong
about nearly everything else why would
he be right
on solely issues of spirituality when
speaking ex Cathedral if he's if you
don't trust him on anything else if you
don't trust him on International
recommendations you don't trust him on
tax policy you don't trust him on issues
as it relates to cultural Marxism you
don't trust him on issues as it relates
to vaccines okay so we're supposed to
believe that he he can't even get
something right accidentally outside of
speaking on issues of spiritual kind of
the most important issues and only when
speaking in this limited capacity I'm
sorry look I I again we have a lot of
friends we have a lot of Catholics who
work here we also have Catholics who
work here like Kevin's basically an
Square Bears basically Eastern Orthodox
only he still has to claim that he's
Catholic because he does not like this
public well you can't just say that Pope
is full of it
it's got to be a tough so my heart goes
at you it's got to be a tough place to
be right now when this guy is the pope
and not all popes have been that way
this is no it's true a significant
veering I don't know enough about
ratzinger I know he was German
is that all you needed now this broad uh
I keep forgetting Yak Arena yeah yeah
she's always Yak in this breath she was
also a huge proponent of masking in
2021. we are here to talk about masking
up or packing up I promise you we're
doing good so far just keep your
distance get your hands washed off and
get tested often and wear your mask
that'll get us closer and closer to
normal days just be clear mask up or
pack up means you better wear a mask or
you're going to be fired yes there you
go and get your hands washed yeah
depending on when that was released in
2021 that that matters the beginning of
less offensive but I'm sorry I I don't
know that I give people a whole lot of a
pass here because at the end of 2020 we
were starting to go this is really
widespread opening should be happening
again we were back to normal here yeah
we were in in the great state of Texas
but a lot of the places were not but 21
I still see a lot of people with masks
out in public okay that's a question for
you guys you still see people and how do
you how do you uh how do you converse
with them I just always I always say ah
thanks for keeping me safe if you're
sick
there you go I'm not sick I go then why
are you wearing a mask now there is
science to show that if you are sick
that wearing a mask can probably help
because again it's right up against your
against your filthy Grill to help
prevent the spread of droplets there's
some science yes there is some science
there but again not if it's being reused
and not if it's not properly fitted but
it does not help you at all the science
is quite settled it does not help you
avoid getting coveted or in this case
the flu so when I see people with Mexico
Oh feeling sick and if they say no I
just go
I look at them with horror on my face
like they're about to knock over the
Kroger I saw a guy the other day with a
bandana on his face walking around
yeah that was that was a member of MS-13
that's all okay I was going to say Crips
but that's better you have to go by the
face tattoos sometimes teardrops yes
yeah neck Tech
so uh pack up upper mask up that means
I'll fire you if you don't mask and by
the way she's also used her platform
this is what's most disturbing to me and
then I'll get to her censorship stances
uh to push for the you know you use we
use the term Dei it's diversity Equity
inclusion genders now listen to The
Numbers at the end of this clip and they
just aren't even feasible under the
leadership of Brian Roberts and Jeff
show uh Comcast set up a fund to the
value of a hundred million dollars to
fight social justice and equality
and and obviously supporting many many
important groups so then we had to make
sure we were taking the right steps to
direct funds towards the right
organizations to make a public statement
of accountability like Caesar Conde our
new chairman of news who made a public
statement that was confronting editorial
bias and saying my division our news
division the biggest news division in
the country is going to be 50 women and
50 people of color
yeah also I mean 50 women was she
talking about Brewing
and 50 people of color okay so you're
going to have to draw 50 by the way
that's 100 if she meant 50 both women
and people of color that's a stupid
statement either way the math doesn't
make sense 12 of the population if we're
talking about the United States are
going to make up 50 of people in a very
SP A hyperly specialized field of work
yeah the news Division and by the way
that won't it won't even be
representative of the American populace
at large no and most he didn't say what
color she just said people of color oh
okay but in that 12 are men
elderly children right so that number is
well that's that's also four percent but
that's that shouldn't be the way that
you try to structure an organization she
wants to have a news division of
entirely black children you know what I
want I want to make sure that it's a
Level Playing Field and that the best
people end up getting the jobs
yeah there you go well in her defense I
think she was confused she thought WWEF
was WWE did you see that belt over her
shoulder yeah it was a Wonder Woman okay
she's a moral was that in that clip go
back yeah is it this clip let me see the
belt over her shoulder amongst all the
awards that's the Intercontinental oh
yeah that is that's it that's a
professional arrest that's theater
Continental Championship right there let
me tell you about the world economic
form the cream's gonna rise to the
topic
I just set him up that's what I do
wind them up little Ultimate Warrior
action yeah I'd be at the riddle welcome
to Wine world one nightmare after the
death
[Laughter]
at the end of that though she did do a
little
she has the Hogan stash bleaching it
doesn't work sweetheart now but really
she has she has no world view she has no
values you can tell you know Dennis
Miller says someone of that age you've
lived in asshole's life yeah you haven't
thought about such things she just
floats from one side she doesn't care
now she's working for Twitter she'll
develop some world view that'll be
comfortable for her there I mean
unbelievable how she's although she does
seem to have a world view which is this
is very disconcerting on the idea of
freedom of speech and this goes to the
point that we made earlier do you
understand there's a huge gap and a
difference between
um the advertisers the woke corporations
with the ESG scores and you the viewer
the user and I really was happy by the
way some people were reaching out going
like oh Twitter's gonna do uh going to
do streaming is that bad for him no I
want to see for example let's say Tucker
Carlson is streaming on Twitter he may
or may not end up streaming on Rumble I
want him to do well and I want Twitter
to do well and I want Rumble to do well
I want everyone to do well not named
YouTube Facebook tick tock
just to be clear there need to be viable
Alternatives we live through the Dark
Ages where everyone said well you just
have to go to YouTube and now the vast
majority of you watch on rumble or on
mug club that to me and by the way we
were willing to take a 50 haircut on
viewership in migrating everyone over
from YouTube instead you guys increased
that shows how ready you were for an
exodus so I want all these places to do
well a little concern to the direction
of Twitter though because here is this
woman discussing her views on free
speech and again she talks about not the
user not what you the people want what
the giant advertising corporations want
if I were to say yes you can influence
me that would be wrong
that would be very wrong that means that
would be a diminishment of freedom of
speech but I want to be specific about
influencing it's more of an open
feedback loop for the advertising
experts in this room
to help
develop Twitter into a place where they
will be excited about investing more
money product development ad safety sure
content moderation yeah because that's
how you're going to create the best
platform is with a group of advertising
Executives deciding to sanitize it and
shape it in the image of what they would
like to see
a bunch of multi-millionaires in a room
at a board meeting that's what's going
to make Twitter the cool place that kids
want to go yeah pharmaceutical company
yes exactly I'm sure what they want is
what the pope said yeah yeah her policy
was at NBC Universe yes exactly I want a
Johnson Johnson social media site she
basically I mean that was that's that
that's actually making the hairs on the
back of my neck stand up because Elon
Musk was right if I allow you to
influence me that would be wrong because
then that would diminish freedom of
speech which is what I'm all about and
she's like well hold on don't think
about it like that and then she
describes the diminishment of freedom of
speech in a different way and says it's
okay yes like that's the part where I'm
like she does get it right she
understands exactly what she's saying
content moderation for ad friendly make
it into a place they feel comfortable
they have the power not you and by the
way when it's only a few companies that
just to give you some inside baseball
here matter of fact we can you know we
can include on mug Club why the left is
upset yeah just to give you a little bit
of inside baseball
um first let me go to the uh the
difference between yeah Turkish
government Twitter and and uh Rumble but
I think this is pretty important this is
what we live through with YouTube by the
way and this is why I am so vehement in
the fact that the right needs to be they
need to um divest they need to uncouple
from Big tech companies and I don't care
how you do it is when you have let's say
uh five companies five companies
basically are in charge of all media
right you have NBC Universal you have
ABC Disney you have Comcast uh Viacom uh
news core let's call it five six seven
companies okay and then they are trying
to get into your news feed into your
whatever your algorithmic feed now it's
not even a news feed on Facebook on
YouTube guess what they spend the
advertising dollars so now you have a
platform that is beholden to five or six
companies who by the way have regular
meetings in a room with each other it
doesn't require a crazy conspiracy
theory to to say hold on a second it
seems like these companies may be in
cahoots if they all removed Alex Jones
the same day so then these people
dictate the advertising remember we had
a conversation with CEOs I should say
sorry Executives at YouTube and they
said well you know you're you're uh uh
there's no Community guidelines but uh
strikes
and we we would say though you're not
Advertiser friendly but we're creating
this new rule borderline content I said
hold on a second you are talking to an
Advertiser on YouTube I said what I said
it's one of the only places that I spend
money to advertise our Channel Hey
subscribe to my channel I said and I
can't actually Target or Reach people
who I would like to reach for example I
would like to reach people who are
interested in the Second Amendment and
by the way I would like to be able to
determine who advertises on my channel I
said would this be a solution to YouTube
listen not Advertiser friendly I said
well what about uh firearm well we can't
do that okay well what about companies
that uh might sell firearm accessories
no okay what about companies that maybe
for example particularly freedom-minded
well those companies don't hold on a
second how about you create a solution
where you pair my Channel with companies
who would actually pay premium to
advertise in that 18 to 45 demo and
recognize that these people are more
conservative we've ended up doing that
with sponsors who by the way never leave
because of your purchasing power YouTube
said well that's not really how it works
what does that mean it means the
advertising is algorithmic and it is
determined by a handful of companies all
of whom are beholden to places like at
wef and International conglomerates in
the ESG score and woke they're
not interesting and actually pairing
advertisers with the right users they
want to manipulate and engineer the
behavior of the users and that's why I
have a problem when conservatives say
well if you can't beat them join them no
no if you can't beat them try harder and
make them wish they picked somebody else
I've been on both sides of advertising
and receiving advertising dollars now we
have not received advertising dollars on
YouTube or any major uh social media
outlet for is it four is it five years
now I know how it works it's a rigged
game and so when someone is saying the
people who are rigging the game need to
be granted more power that's a problem
and it's very clear with this lady's
language that that's what she's she's
interested in doing and also just to be
clear here's another misstep with uh
with with Twitter that I'm concerned
with
[Applause]
[Laughter]
drank his coffee this morning so uh at
the behalf of the Turkish government and
I think Elon has largely been a positive
force certainly for Direct
but Twitter agreed to restrict access to
some tweets from the Turkish government
at their request during the presidential
election
and uh this is actually a quote
responding to online criticism from
Maddie Iglesias musk tweeted did your
brain fall out of your head Iglesias the
choices have Twitter throttled in its
entirety or limit access to some tweets
which one do you want now this is
important because we have a direct
contrast and again I would love to see
Twitter do well and I would love to see
Rumble do well but people are asked you
want to know why we partnered with
Rumble and you want to know what excites
me uh with Rumble if you have kids they
should leave okay because I'm just gonna
it's like Donald Trump is this with the
vote
it's the you platform
so when Elon Musk says he's basically
saying I was just doing my job you said
you would kill me less were you stupid
did your brain fall off your head
Iglesias the choices have Twitter
throttle in its entirety or limit access
to some tweets which one do you want
Rumble had that exact same scenario they
were demanded by France to remove Russia
today as a Channel or any of its content
from their platform and they FL they
said okay well then you're just gonna
have to remove Rumble as a platform they
issued a statement saying recently the
French government demanded that we
remove certain Russian news sources from
Rumble as part of our mission to restore
a free and open internet we have
committed not to move the goal posts on
our content yeah so one response from
Elon Musk what would you have us do
exactly what Rumble did Rumble said all
right the French government
how about that okay how about I'm sorry
I meant that this and this
that's what Rumble said and as a
consequence Rumble was banned at least
for period of time I don't know if they
still are right in all of France you
cannot set the precedent do you have any
idea what that's going you're counting
to the Turkish what's going to happen
with China yeah exactly by the way this
is during an election season like you
don't do what the government wants you
to do in a tight election no it means
censoring certain points of view just
because you think a little bit of
Twitter is better no it's not you know
why a little bit of Twitter makes you
think that there is honesty right if
you've got Twitter still there you're
thinking okay well Twitter's still the
Free Speech platformer I didn't hear the
story about them Banning these a couple
of accounts or maybe these dozens of
tweets maybe that are maybe I didn't
hear all that and I think I'm getting
the full truth but I'm not it's where we
are today it is the Blue Planet
blueprint for censorship golly did I
have a stroke today Joe Biden he maybe
did I don't know man I just think you
should have some Twitter yeah what are
we doing and Texas is big bigger than
France anyway you know they really don't
they don't matter it's not enough people
to matter
they don't make a difference they're too
busy man they'll come flying and eating
cheese no they'll come begging for
Twitter soon I mean yeah I would Rumble
you know because they're still begging
for rumble and yeah of course look you
can't do this you can't count out to
these other governments and I understand
what some of you are going to say like
well also in Russia Today could be it's
partially invited by the Kremlin Russia
propaganda okay sure but again the the
point of view from rum from Rumble is
also anti-russia today channels are
allowed on Rumble right it's an open
discourse what's more damaging than
um Mitch is lies or mistreuths are half
truths and that's what Twitter is doing
with I I'm using the word correctly
being in collusion to a degree with the
Turkish government so it doesn't just
exist in this vacuum of well hold on is
there no we we have we have precedent
remotel friends to go screw themselves
and Elon Musk is already starting from
the point of view of well what do you
want some Twitter or no Twitter I think
as it relates to Turkey they get no
Twitter how about that you know what if
you don't finish your dinner you don't
get your snow cone okay the Turkish
government you don't allow freedom for
everyone then you get no Twitter that
needs to happen enough where these
governments then understand hold on a
second we can't just keep we can't just
keep calling the shots do you have any
idea how many tweets that I have or did
for a long time that are not available
in Germany because it's in violation of
German speech laws or Pakistan
positively when I hang you I just think
Pakistan should have no Stephen Crowder
Twitter you can follow me at s Crowder
let me know if in Pakistan you get any
of it I would be very surprised but
basically look if if Twitter had taken a
stand this is Elon look this is the
Playbook if you take a stand in turkey
and say no we're not self-censoring
either the government backs down and you
win free speech wins or you get banned
and the people see it in broad daylight
exactly that their government is Banning
speech and maybe that leads to change in
the government not the easement strategy
that you just put in play that's good
that's absolutely right and I think that
combined with the fact that this woman
is very clearly more interested in
creating Twitter and social media
platforms and the new world because
let's be honest that's where people
often live that's where people exchange
information it's a digital Town Square
she wants to rebuild that in the image
of what advertisers want as opposed to
what you the user the viewer wants you
are true north you Richard North the
moment that you say you know what we're
done a I'll go retire and I'll go do
something else we've talked about this
um half the stuff that you see here was
pitched at some point when I was at Fox
News or at any of the networks and now
that's never going to work you have
decided to make it work because you are
true and I think that's why this show is
very different and that's why we're
really happy to be in a partnership with
Rumble and I hope that Twitter gets
their together and I hope that
there's healthy competition but right
now as it relates to Yak Arena I'm not
seeing it we're going to continue this
by the way on Mud Club
Club again you can send your proof of
any right wing streaming uh purchase
right subscription to Fremont club
Atlanta with credit.com and we will send
you three months free those emails are
going out so check your email you're not
getting any other spam you'll get a
promo code boom three months free if you
don't like it you can bounce you get
this show you get the Friday show you
get Nick depalo and you would get right
now if you're on Rumble just click that
button right there click it right there
that button right there I know oh it
stings click it and you get to continue
watching the show every day another 45
minutes to an hour depending on how long
the bathroom break is for pop scratter
who has the prostate the size of a
grapefruit YouTube not thank you but
Rumble thank you YouTube piss off
powered by Rumble we'll continue this
foreign
[Music]